rebel fighters approach a convoy of
burning vehicles on christmas eve
it was the scene of a massacre they say
more than 30 men women and children
executed their bodies burned
they say it was myanmar's army
specifically the much-feared 66th light
infantry
myanmar's military leadership have
denied involvement
but those tactics are well known to
captain miento whose name we've changed
for security reasons he served in the
66th flight infantry until november when
he deserted now he's in hiding
he says he and his soldiers were taught
to believe that anyone who stood up to
them was the enemy
the army sees the ethnic groups like
terrorists they tell the soldiers that
all the ethnic groups are terrorists
that's why they fight against them they
want to control everything
despite decades of oppressive rule
members of myanmar's army or tatmador as
they're often called inside the country
were held in high regard
their role as guardians of a divided
nation often superseded reports of
atrocities
against ethnic minorities including the
rohingya
last year's military coup changed all
that
the stature and the reputation
of the tapidah have taken a massive hit
the people of myanmar quite quite
frankly hate them and view them as
terrorists at one stage it was thought
that the trickle of defectors coming
from over there in myanmar might turn
into a flood that didn't happen the army
closed ranks and since then it's been
very hard to know what's going on in
military mines
high on a misty hillside along the time
myanmar border we got a rare insight
into the concerns of enlisted soldiers
as we filmed a border outpost several
soldiers in plain clothes approached us
friendly they chatted openly in english
and tie
were they worried about the fierce
fighting going on between myanmar's army
and its people if
talking like about the organization is
we worrying about that but in this
region like in this side we don't have
any problem about that another anime
group yeah but are you worried about the
fighting inside myanmar as well yeah
yeah a little bit
[Music]
captain
can be more open about his concerns
since february there's no happiness he
sings
my homeland is destroyed
now he's committed to fighting against
the army a fight the song lyric says
we will win
tony chang al jazeera on the time
myanmar border